y ocho días caminando desde honduras y
todavía faltan más de 1000 kilómetros
para llegar a la frontera de méxico con
estados unidos es que nosotros no
venimos aquí porque se nos antoja sino
que por la necesidad que tenemos mal
afortunadamente esto no lo entiende
nadie como miles de migrantes huyen de
la pobreza y la violencia de
centroamérica pero éstos han decidido
abandonar el objetivo de llegar a eeuu y
por ahora buscarán fortuna en méxico
eeuu esa era la meta hasta el momento
porque ya estamos cansados de tanto
también de hallar los pies ellas nos dan
malla estamos dando las últimas ya no
queremos y no tenemos dinero para seguir
para los que sí consiguen llegar a la
frontera con eeuu las perspectivas de
futuro no son mucho mejores este fin de
semana se publicaron unas fotos que
muestran a docenas de migrantes
amontonados en los centros de detención
fronterizos la mayoría de ellos serán
deportados bajo el argumento de la
emergencia sanitaria los menores no
acompañados podrán quedarse en eeuu pero
muchas veces deben pasar varios días en
las estaciones policiales
los niños que llegan a nuestra frontera
que huyen de la violencia que huyen de
la persecución que huyen de situaciones
difíciles no es una crisis es una crisis
y creemos que es nuestra responsabilidad
de abordar esta situación con humanidad
y asegurarnos que sean tratados
impuestos en condiciones seguras sin ser
safe el gobierno de joe biden trata de
disuadir a los migrantes que viajan
esperanzados por el discurso más
humanizado del presidente demócrata
representantes de la casa blanca ya
están en méxico y guatemala para
conseguir la colaboración de los
gobiernos
y a pesar de que los obstáculos cada vez
son más como la creciente militarización
de la frontera sur de méxico miles de
centroamericanos siguen persiguiendo el
sueño del migrante